as everyone knows elections are under
attack that's why Trump created the
presidential Advisory Commission on
election integrity to crack down on all
the dead people undocumented immigrants
and well trained dogs illegally pulling
the lever for the left but tragically
just a few days ago the USA Today
reported that Trump's Commission may
have gone dark amid a deluge of lawsuits
luckily the opposition's own one-man
election integrity Commission Tim bolts
is on the case
watch I was shocked last year when
people said our commander in chief lost
the popular vote that can only be true
if you count the millions of votes that
were cast illegally and I know voter
fraud is one of the biggest problems
facing America especially in the States
Trump theoretically lost like New
Hampshire this issue of bussing voters
into New Hampshire is widely known by
anyone who's worked in New Hampshire
politics it's very real it's very
serious but not everyone agrees like
this snowflake the idea that people are
coming to New Hampshire to commit fraud
on a massive scale like this is just
preposterous and it needs to be called
out as untrue so I am facing off with
New Hampshire political expert Fergus
calling to call him out as untrue voter
fraud is real it's happening on a wide
scale and millions of people voted
illegally last year there is no such
thing as widespread voter fraud well
that's exactly what I'd expect a
Democrat like you to say yeah I'm again
a Republican in fact a former chairman
of the state Republican Party I'm sorry
what this turncoat is so sure there's no
fraud happening in the state that he's
offering a thousand dollar bounty to
anyone who can prove otherwise is that a
real offer oh yes absolutely I have
offered $1,000 to anyone who can prove
that so much as one person took a bus
from Massachusetts to any polling place
in New Hampshire on election day and
voted so you have $1,000
yes $1,000 I have never seen $1,000 is
it a single bill I am so doing this
any good businessman knows that you got
to spend money to make money so I
rendered this man I hired a crew
obviously there's like gas mileage all
that stuff you know miscellaneous income
but I'm gonna get that thousand dollars
I mean - all those expenses but the ROI
on this investment will be huge because
I found someone with irrefutable proof
New Hampshire state representative and
Trump advisor al baldesarra
one of my constituents came over to me
she said el voter fraud is going on over
here she was pissed what are these
pictures is these a picture of
automobiles that parked across the
street The Smoking Gun photos of
out-of-state plates in a parking lot
somewhere when I Drive around and smell
these casa that's a blow-up woman on a
Saturday or Sunday I see them from all
over I don't see him during the week as
much so are we at a crime scene right
now
yes election fraud I'm gonna blow this
case wide open
some people have said that voter fraud
is up to three percent to twenty five
percent that's across the country like
actually now it's point zero zero zero
three two point zero zero to five but
the bottom line is voter fraud is going
on
I'm about to be thick with bills so you
know I'm celebrating
you're a businessman in a big job get
the rewards I hope you have that $1,000
ready for me Massachusetts Massachusetts
Florida people came from all over to
vote illegally in New Hampshire what I
see is cars with out-of-state license
plates being parked in parking lots what
proof do you have that they cast a
ballot this is proof a voter fraud in
New Hampshire there's no evidence here
that any of these people voted you know
I really wish that the same camera that
took these pictures also had you know
video capability and that what we had
was a video okay fine better proof it's
like this guy doesn't even know how
license plates work time for Plan B in
September the co-chair of Trump's
election integrity commission published
an article on Breitbart detailing how
thousands of people voted in New
Hampshire with an out of state license
but never went on to get an in-state ID
many in the MSM say oh those are just
out of state college students who've
dorm in New Hampshire legally allowed to
vote there he accused completely
unfairly thousands of college students
in New Hampshire who lived there the pay
ran to pay tuition of being criminals
all I heard was college students are
criminals so I shelled out a little more
money to go deep undercover at the
University of New Hampshire catch these
kids in your tracks
just fill up the flip rolls it's
disgusting
you New Hampshire resident no for real
yeah see him how to save license very
cool
did you vote in the last election yeah
that like how all the illegal people
voted here how many times did you vote
illegally and then you voted in your
home state a couple more times nice
shirt oh thank you yeah I'm a big
liberal I love voting and politics I
mean you don't have to like walk around
the issue with me I am down to vote
illegally hey what's up man hey you
going any ragers this weekend no not
this weekend is all last week good yeah
me too yeah give you 40 bucks just say I
voted illegally in New Hampshire you're
paying me 40 bucks yeah and then I admit
that I did a felony yes yeah yeah yeah I
got all the proof that I need I did
$5,000 finally it was time to collect my
reward I have something that I think you
will find very interesting I talked to a
ton of college kids and let me tell you
they are brazen and after I show you
this and I get the money I'm taking this
straight to the FBI did you vote yet
lost election yep
you vote more than once oh yeah boom I
told you he voted illegally hey man give
you 40 bucks just say I voted illegally
it's not what it seems that guy paid me
to say that stuff and I needed the money
because I needed a thousand dollars
mm-hmm dammit he wouldn't take my proof
good thing the state of New Hampshire
didn't need proof to pass a new law that
will likely make it more difficult for
students to vote and you know I'm
keeping that vape pen yeah baby
[Music]